you were talking about becoming a global
citizen what does that mean like
there's just being like more numbers on
the car thing too i've never been
our guy yeah and i i remember driving
with you and you're in your car it was a
bmw pretty fast one years ago
and i love the feeling and the power and
i remember looking at you going
i just looked successful like you just
looked and felt successful in this car
was it like a six series or something do
you remember what you had uh
i think that's when i picked you up from
the airport and three convertible
so that was like a 414 horsepower v8 but
but it sounded really nice like it's
powerful yeah so so years ago i went out
and bought my
i was driving a saab and then i drove
another saab and then i went out and
bought a fully loaded p90d
tesla [ __ ] loaded it with everything
130 000 us
bought and never even drove test drove
it i just like went and picked it up
like holy [ __ ] man i don't know what
we've been driving but they're not cars
like that is just ridiculous so
i i get it now and every single day i
sat down in it i loved it and felt
successful and i would tell any single
guy out there
buy yourself the car that you want to be
driving before you buy anybody else
anything
before you buy anything else for your
kids before you buy anything else for
your spouse before you pay anything for
your parents
buy yourself the car or lease the car
for the next three years you are going
to feel
good like every time i sit in my cars
now i feel good
right now in vancouver i've got an audi
q8 like fully decked out
suv because i'm in the mountains but
every time i sit in it i'm like
i feel good like there's some that that
transfers into the way i walk into the
coffee shop or the way i show up on my
calls and
it's a really weird segue moment but i
get it
it's interesting that you say that
because there's a lot of guys i know
this like you wouldn't even know that
that
that they're loaded i think there was
one interview that jeff bezos did where
he was driving this
shitty old honda van yeah and like the
reporters like okay you're the richest
guy in the world why are you driving
this car sort of thing why aren't you in
the back of a rolls royce with a
you know with somebody driving but
there's a lot of guys um out there
that that are that are super successful
but they're not car guys i was actually
surprised because when i was a kid i
thought everybody was a car guy because
all my friends were car guys we'd like
cars a lot we always did like these big
burnouts and we were doing donuts in the
winter time in the parking lots and all
that kind of stuff
and then as i got older and i started to
you know start reading books like you
know richard branson's biography he
never talked about cars once you know he
talked about doing balloons and
racing across the ocean in a power boat
um
you know you read up on steve jobs and
he like the nicest car he had was an
older mercedes that he never even played
it like you basically use this technique
to never plate the car
yeah my mine is a mine is a treating
myself
with something that is going to to pay
off time and time again
so you mentioned the hermann miller
chair i've got a herman miller air on
chair at my office desk
50 60 feet from me i only fly first
class now
but people people are like oh is that an
ego thing no i actually have met more
business deals sitting in first class
than i've ever met sitting in economy i
landed
the country of of qatar because i sat
beside the second in command for the
country
on a flight from vancouver to phoenix i
landed the ceo of sprint
i've landed speaking events so now i'm
like wait a second i'm going to pay to
put myself
in that spot because i'm around
successful people i'm going to pay to
put myself in a nice car because it
makes me feel good every single day
i'm going to pay to sit in the in the
best chair out there because i feel good
eight hours a day when i'm sitting in it
right now i'm sitting in a three
thousand dollar leather shades that i do
work from i don't know if you can see
are you in the same one the hardware
yeah that's
[ __ ] amazing i love this thing and
then i and then i trout when i travel i
stay in nice hotels or i stay in really
really baller you know airbnbs
because it feels good now and then i
might cut back a little bit on the fact
that
yeah i wear a lululemon sweatshirt
because it doesn't really give a [ __ ]
well they're actually pretty comfortable
i guess
you